When in the course of human events it
becomes necessary for one people to
dissolve the political bands which
have connected them with another and to
assume among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station to which the
laws of nature and of
nature's God entitled them.
A decent respect to the opinions of
mankind requires that they should declare
the causes which impelled
them to the separation.
We hold these truths to be self
evident that all men are created equal,
that they are endowed by the creator
with certain unalienable rights.
That among these are life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness that
to secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the governed.
That whenever any form of government
becomes destructive of these ends,
it is the right of the people
to alter or abolish it.
And to institute a new government laying
its foundation on such principles and
organizing its powers in such form as
to them shall seem most likely to effect
their safety and happiness.
Prudence indeed will dictate that
governments long established should not be
changed for light and transient causes
and accordingly all experience hath shown
that mankind are more disposed to suffer
while evils are sufferable than to
right themselves by abolishing the
forms to which they are accustomed.
But when a long train of abuses and
usurpations pursuing invariably the same
object events is it designed to reduce
them under absolute despotism it is their
right.
It is their duty to throw off such
government and to provide new guards for
their future security.
Such has been the patient sufferance of
these colonies and such is now than it
says that he was constrained as them to
alter their former systems of government.
The history of the present king of
Great Britain has a history of repeated
injuries and usurpations all having in
direct object the establishment of an
absolute tyranny over
these states to prove this,
let facts be submitted to a candid world.
He has refused his assent to laws the
most wholesome and necessary for the
public good.
He has forbidden,
has governors to pass laws of immediate
and pressing importance and less
suspended and their operation till has
essentially be obtained and when so
suspended he has utterly
neglected to attend to them.
He has refused to pass the real loss for
the accommodation of large districts of
people unless those people
would relinquish the right
of representation in the
legislature or write an estimable to
them and formidable to tyrants only.
He has called together legislative
bodies that places unusual,
uncomfortable and distant
from the pository of their
public records for the sole
purpose of fatiguing them into
compliance with his measures.
He has dissolved representative houses
repeatedly for opposing with manly
firmness has invasions on the rights
of the people he has refused for a long
time after such dissolutions to cause
others to be elected whereby the
legislative powers and
capable of annihilation have
returned to the people at
large for their exercise.
The state remaining in the
meantime exposed to all the
dangers of invasion from
without and convulsions within.
He has endeavored to prevent
the population of these
states for that purpose of
struck and laws of
naturalization of foreigners.
Refusing the past others to
encourage them migration,
Heather and raising the conditions
of new appropriations of lands.
He has obstructed the administration of
justice for refusing because it's sent
to laws for establishing judiciary powers.
He has made judges dependent on his will
alone for tenure of their offices and
the amounts and payment of their salaries.
He has erected a multitude of new offices
and sent Heather swarms of officers to
harass our people and
eat out their substance.
He has kept among us in times of peace
standing armies without the consent of
our legislature.
He has affected to render the military
independent of and superior to the civil
power he has combined with others to
subject us to jurisdictions foreign to our
constitution and unacknowledged
by our laws, giving his ascent,
their acts of pretended legislation for
quartering large bodies of arm troops
among us for protecting them by a mock
trial from punishment for any murders
which they should commit
on the inhabitants of these
states for cutting off our
trade with all parts of the world,
for imposing taxes on us without
our consent for depriving us in.
Many cases of the benefits of trial by
jury for transporting us beyond sees to
be tried for pretended offenses,
for abolishing the free system of
English flaws in a neighboring province,
establishing their in an
arbitrary government and
enlarging its boundaries so as
to render it at once and example and
fit instrument for introducing the same
absolute rule into these colonies
for taking away our charters,
abolishing our most valuable laws and
altering fundamentally to forms of our
governments for suspending our own
legislature's and declaring themselves
invested with power to legislate for
all of us in all cases whatsoever.
He has abdicated government here by
declaring us out of his protection and
waging war against us. He has
plundered our CS, ravaged our coast,
burnt our towns in his store,
the lives of our people.
He is at this time transporting
large armies of foreign mercenary.
See Complete the works of death,
desolation and tyranny already begun
with circumstances of cruelty, imperfect.
He's scarcely paralleled in
the most barbarous age as
in totally unworthy of the
head of a civilized nation.
He has constrained our fellow citizens
taking captive on the high seas to bear
arms against their country to become
the executioners of their friends and
brethren or to follow
themselves by their hands.
He has excited the mastic insurrections
amongst us and has endeavored to bring
on the inhabitance of our frontiers,
the merciless Indian savages whose known
rule of warfare as an undistinguished
destruction of all ages,
sexes, and conditions.
In every stage of these oppressions,
we have petition for redress.
In the most humble terms,
our repeated petitions have been
answered only by repeated injury.
A prince who his character
is us marked by every act,
which made a finance [inaudible] is
unfit to be the ruler of a free people.
Nor have we been wanting an
attention to our British brethren.
We have warned them from time to time
of attempts by the legislature to extend
an unwarranted ball jurisdiction over us.
We have reminded them of the circumstances
of our immigration and settlements
here we have appeal to
their native justice and
magnanimity and we have conjured
them by the ties of our common kindreds
disavow these years for patients which
would inevitably interrupt our
connections in correspondence.
They too have been desta voice
of Justice and constantly windy.
We must therefore acquiesce
and the necessity which
announces our separation and
holds them as we hold the rest of mankind,
enemies in war and peace,
friends,
we therefore the representatives of the
United States of America in general,
Congress assembled appealing to
the supreme judge of the world,
of the rectitude of our intentions.
Do in the name and by the authority
of the good people of these colonies,
solemnly publish and declare that these
United colonies are and of right ought
to be free and independent states,
that they're absolved from all
allegiance to the British crown.
And that all political connection between
them and the state of Great Britain is
and ought to be totally dissolved.
And that as free and independent states,
they have full power to levy war
include piece, contract alliances,
established commerce,
and so all the other acts and things
which independent states may have right.
Do and for the support of this
declaration with a firm reliance on the
protection of divine providence, we
mutually pledge to each other our lives,
our fortunes,
and our sacred honor.